il est 10h20 Aurore Bergé arrive à
l'Assemblée nationale une rentrée
parlementaire particulière pour
livelinoise pour son second mandat au
Palais Bourbon elle a été élue
présidente du groupe Renaissance le 22
juin dernier par les députés du groupe
j'ai 170 députés donc 169 autour de moi
avec moi et donc il faut évidemment
porter un collectif ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire définir des lignes des objets
politiques qu'on a envie à un moment de
porter dans le débat public ça définit
qui on est et puis j'oublie pas le
territoire évidemment elle suit
d'Yvelines et donc je continue à
arpenter tous les week-ends
premier rendez-vous la réunion avec les
groupes modèles et horizons qui
composent la majorité présidentielle un
rendez-vous inter-groupe effectué une
fois par mois objectif assurer la
cohésion de la majorité tout en laissant
des marges de manœuvre individuelle aux
députés c'est pas la caserne encore une
fois d'être dans un groupe politique un
choix d'appartenir un groupe politique
c'est un choix d'appartenir à un
collectif et moi ma responsabilité c'est
d'animer le collectif c'est quoi la
ligne qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire moi je
dis voilà ce que je recommande après
chacun est libre parce qu'à la fin
chacun est jugé individuellement aussi
en tant que député et chacun a été élu
individuellement en tant que député pour
occuper cette nouvelle fonction comme la
une de la première victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron affiché dans son bureau Aurore
Berger a osé en général dans la vie
qu'elle soit je pense qu'à un moment il
faut pas attendre qu'on vous donne les
choses il faut y aller il faut oser
prendre la parole il faut oser
s'exprimer il faut aussi avoir de la
cohérence dans les positions qui sont
les mots dans les propositions que vous
portez moi je suis très fière que la
première proposition de loi de mon
groupe ce soit sur la garantie de
l'accès d'IVG pour toutes les femmes et
je crois que s'ils m'ont choisi c'est
parce que peut-être j'avais de
l'expérience du précédent mandat que
j'avais la personnalité qui est la
mienne où ils savent que je peux aller
au combat pour eux que je peux aller au
combat dans l'hémicycle mais que je peux
aussi aller au combat pour obtenir
vis-à-vis du gouvernement un certain
genre de choses combattant elle l'a
encore démontré ce jour-là dans
l'hémicycle Aurore berger à interpeller
la première ministre sur les violences
conjugales en faisant allusion à
l'affaire cadenas depuis plusieurs
semaines on fait fier des règles
élémentaires de l'État de droit
s'il vous plaît je crois que ce sujet
appelle le calme et non le trouble ou le
désordre je crois que ce sujet mérite
mieux que des esclandre et je suis navré
que vous reconnaissiez si bien dans les
propos que j'ai exprimé et pour la
présidente du groupe Renaissance la
tâche ne fait que commencer dans un
contexte de majorité relative une
situation inédite à l'Assemblée
nationale ou le gouvernement et les
groupes de la majorité présidentielle
vont devoir aller chercher des compromis
ou utiliser l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution